hello I'm mark powers senior director of
R&D for the cell biology business at
thermo fisher scientific we're excited
to bring together researchers from
across the world today to learn about
new scientific advances expand your
research network and discover the newest
innovations for stem cell research a
thermo fisher scientific we are
committed to enabling our customers to
make the world healthier cleaner and
safer our goal for this event is to
enable you to make the discoveries that
will lead to a healthier tomorrow by
creating a forum to share and
collaborate with researchers around the
world with that I'm excited to welcome
you all to the fourth annual 24 hours of
stem cells event thank you for joining
us today and enjoy the show before you
begin exploring first make sure to
review your personal profile settings
set your personal profile settings using
the profile settings menu on the
navigation bar your screen name and
other personal details are listed here
you can easily change what information
is made available to other attendees in
the virtual environment by checking the
small box to the right of each detail
when the green check mark shows that
information is visible on your public
profile for all attendees under the
general settings tab here you can also
select your preferred event time zone
and language customizing your event time
zone will allow you to view the schedule
of live presentations and chats in your
preferred time zone customizing your
event language will change some of the
navigation buttons and menus to your
preferred language now that your profile
is set let's review what's available in
this year's event if you are interested
in the event certification you can view
the list of required activities here to
earn the event certification you will
need to complete all activities on this
list activities must be completed in the
order they're shown track your progress
under the activities tab to see how
you're doing once you have completed all
five activities you will be able to
download your certificate of completion
you will receive an email shortly after
with instructions on requesting your
t-shirt if you're interested in more
training and education resources for
em cells be sure to visit the Learning
Center here you can participate in
various gibco virtual training labs
including basic cell culture
transfection and pluripotent stem cell
culture recorded PSE training modules
from our stem cell experts are also
available don't miss out on these great
educational and training resources there
are two areas to listen to the
presentations available in this event
on-demand presentations are here watch
these presentations at your leisure or
save them to your briefcase for later
the live presentations and schedule of
events can be found here this is your
chance to connect with thought leaders
and prominent researchers from around
the world in the exhibit hall you can
visit booths to learn about new
technologies products and resources
available to support your stem cell
research there are a few things to
mention about your experience in the
exhibit hall in a booth you can view and
learn about new products and services
offered by thermo fisher scientific for
stem cell research browse the different
resources available by application you
can choose to view them now or save them
for later by adding them to your virtual
briefcase here you can find a schedule
of the live chats that will be hosted by
thermo fisher scientific sardi experts
visit during your topic of interest join
the conversation and ask our team your
questions from modeling diseases to
discovering therapies and perhaps one
day even offering cures stem cells have
the potential to change the way we think
about medicine sharing new findings
research approaches and connecting with
other researchers is a great way to move
stem cell research forward thank you for
attending today's virtual event